if you watch the news at all back in the
summer of 2016
you probably remember stories like these
the guy who is brash a guy who is blunt
americans aren't willing to trust her
don't think she's honest the news spent
a lot of time dissecting the candidates
personalities
he's very forward and he's a little bit
vicious analyzing their poll numbers
closing the gap in states that matter
most and psychoanalyzing their
supporters
these stories are part of a long
tradition of political journalism
where the goal is to make you feel like
an insider
someone with all the information on
who's up who's down in which states with
which groups
and this kind of coverage basically
treats an election
like a big event sanders warren
a competition a show and it's designed
to make you feel smart
as someone watching the election donald
trump doing very well across the middle
kind of like how knowing all the stats
about a sports team makes you feel
really smart when you're watching the
game
donald trump in july 80 million dollars
by far his best month to date
though that fell short of clinton's 90
million sometimes
we make videos like that here at box but
there's
also another way that journalists can
cover an election
not as a show but as a choice between
plans priorities
and visions for what the country should
do next
this kind of coverage is designed to
make you a smarter voter
or if you don't live in the u.s to at
least help you understand what this
giant election is actually
about that is what we want to make
videos about
between now and election day not about
what's going to happen
in the election but about what might
change after it
to explain that we want your help at the
link below
there's one question we want you to
answer what do you think
the candidates should be talking about
that's it it could be a specific
question like should we break up the big
tech companies
or why aren't more drugs legal why do
american companies give so little
parental leave
should we have more nuclear energy or it
could be a topic that's just
been on your mind lately like what's the
deal with the cost of college
or what's going to happen with college
or transportation
or food security or paying for child
care or student loans
whatever it is tell us at the link below
or at vox.com
election videos what do you think the
candidates
should be talking about what's happening
in your life that you wish they would
pay attention to
your ideas will become the list of
things that we explain
between now and election day then
starting in september we'll put out one
video
every week each video will come from
something you asked us for
and if your question or suggestion
inspired us we'll shout you out in that
video
this year and this election are not
turning out how we thought they would
the way we explained elections shouldn't
stay the same either but first we need
your help
so thanks for watching and thanks for
sticking with us